[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tout le monde
la présente est si ont été faites donc
je vais vous dire assez rapidement
pourquoi je suis là je vais parler de
dessins de dessin provocateur de dessins
qui peuvent être un peu agressif ou un
petit peu rentrer dedans et je vais
essayer de faire un comparatif entre
certains types de dessin certains autres
types de dessin pour commencer bien
évidemment de l'esa a pris une
importance depuis les événements de
charlie et depuis les différents
attentats qui ont eu lieu à paris et à
nice et qui ont donné lieu à cette
occasion là à des publications
importantes de gens qui ont fait des
dessins spontanément pour et des
professionnels aussi mais autour de
tours de ces événements dramatiques
les dessins qui sont plutôt des dessins
on va dire compassionnelle des dessins
[Musique]
je m'habitue et voilà ça y est j'y suis
des dessins qui qui regroupe des images
un peu symbolique pour permettre de de
d'exprimer leur désarroi leur tristesse
leur chagrin leurs colères
éventuellement et ses dessins là il a vu
fleurir principalement dans certaines
pages de journaux beaucoup de sur les
télévisions et c'est parce que
vraisemblablement le focus avait été mis
sur le dessinant sur les dessinateurs de
presse
après les attentats charlie et sur le
média qui est le dessin mais bon ça
c'est ce qu'on va appeler des dessins
qui sont plutôt gentils ça se corse avec
d'autres types de dessin on a eu
d'autres un autre événement dramatique
qui était la noyade du petit taylan qui
a été photographié par une photographe
turc sur les plages de turquie et
l'appareil gros émoi et puis beaucoup de
dessins de qui qui ont paru qui
reprenait la la la silhouette de
l'enfant les couleurs de 2 100 t-shirts
de son de son de son short etc
et puis charlie hebdo a continué son
travail et il ya eu ce dessin de rice
qui a provoqué beaucoup d'émoi et
beaucoup de révolte et donc j'ai essayé
de m'expliquer pourquoi des dessins
gentils sont peut-être pas si bien
intentionnés que ça ou peut-être pas si
utile et comment des dessins qui peuvent
paraître méchant comme celui là parce
qu'on est vraiment dans un des cinq rues
elle peut peut avoir à un rôle positif à
jouer pas forcément facile d'expliquer
la première chose qu'il faut faire c'est
qu'on reparte un petit peu sur ce qui
est d'abord l'image en prenant ce
premier exemple qui est un tableau vous
connaissez sans doute un tableau de
magritte qui
est un peu curieux étonnant puisqu'il
représente une pipe très réaliste et
qu'en dessous il est marqué ceci n'est
pas une pipe alors la question est posée
qu'est ce que c'est est ce que c'est une
lâche une carotte non c'est pas ça
ce que dit magritte là dedans c'est que
un dessin de pipe c'est pas une pipe
saint des saints c'est une peinture donc
sa première des choses à comprendre
ensuite
donc il faut faire le distinguo entre la
chose et de sa représentation ensuite je
vous passe quelques petits dessins qui
pose un petit peu ce problème que j'ai
traité mois autour de la représentation
de entre autres avec le problème des
caricatures de mahomet et voilà donc
petits problèmes entre une image et son
interprétation et sa représentation et
les choses qu'on peut mettre derrière
donc il ya un malentendu qui situe au
niveau de l'image niveau du dessin au
niveau de ces choses là on va aller dans
l'histoire de l'art et de l'histoire des
images à travers différentes peintures
et voir comment à chaque fois ces images
ces peintures sont allés se frictionner
un petit peu sur des tabous sur des
interdits sur des consensus apparent ou
commence avec ce tableau de matisse qui
est une femme court en fauve début du
19e siècle du xxème siècle pardon avec
il a été pris à partie par les tenants
de la peinture classique disant que son
personnage était horrible et il a
répondu
mais oui c'est normal moi si je croisais
les femmes que je dessine dans la rue je
mens furet à toute vitesse ce sont pas
des femmes c'est la peinture même sujet
donc il faut remonter un petit peu à
l'origine de l'expression de l'homme et
on s'aperçoit que le dessin dans le
monde de la peinture rupestre de l'art
pariétal et c'est comme ici à lascaux on
se demande pourquoi dès le départ
l'homme s'est mis à dessiner
alors on a fait plusieurs suppositions
se demandait c'était des scènes de
d'entraînement pour la chasse des
défiguration pédagogiques etc
l'interprétation mais qui me semble la
meilleure c'est de dire que c'était une
façon pour l'homme d'appréhender son
univers son univers c'est à dire que
dans un monde qui est incompréhensible
d'indiquer dans un flux permanent de
d'action avec des animaux qui sont on
sait pas d'où ils viennent ou yvon
qu'est ce qu'ils font et c'est une façon
de s'approprier le réel et c'est une
façon de comprendre le réel est de
donner une lecture du réel
donc là on a cette phrase de shakespeare
qui de macbeth de shakespeare je vous
laisse la lire la partie la plus
intéressante
je laisse une petite minute donc il dit
que le cette histoire dit par un idiot
plein de bruit et de fureur et qui ne
signifie rien donc en fait la vie c'est
un espèce de courant dont on n'a ni les
tenants ni les aboutissants et l'image
comme toute oeuvre d'art est là pour
donner à un moment de cohérence dans le
dans le flux de la vie lors d'un tableau
de malevitch qui était un tableau qui
était contestée parce qu'il était très
très radicale qui date du début du
siècle 1819 19 119 pardon et même s'il
n'y a pas grand chose dans ce tableau là
il a un cadre
donc il a une limite en dehors du cadre
y'a rien et tout se passe à l'intérieur
de ce cadre là et donc c'est une
cohérence en soi et toute oeuvre d'art
c'est à mon avis c'est la
caractéristique de tout de toutes les
oeuvres c'est que ça un début que ça une
fin il ya un déroulement de dents ou une
composition quand c'est de l'image et ça
a une cohérence et ça donne une
cohérence à la vie alors cette cette
histoire donné ce sens donner à la vie
on le retrouve à travers après des
oeuvres qui vont faire des récits et ça
c'est la tapisserie de bayeux qui datent
de 1100 à peu près qui raconte la
conquête de l'angleterre par guillaume
le conquérant et c'est une longue
tapisserie qui fait 70 mètres de long
qui l' une des première bande dessinée
qui raconte en détail toutes les ai
toutes les toutes les aventures de cette
conquête de l'angleterre
donc cette cette peinture cet art
fabrique également des icônes donc du
sens de concret bea d une idéalisation
de personnages de choses et c est donc
ça ça peut contribuer à donner du sens
beaucoup fabrique aussi des icônes et
puis au bout d'un moment lice la
peinture va aussi essayer de se frotter
au réel à l'histoire au cours des choses
et essayer d'aller revoir si derrière
l'histoire officielle n'y a pas des
choses un peu moins prestigieuses là on
à goya qui nous peint une scène
d'exécution
parle d des résistants espagnols par les
armées de conquêtes napoléoniennes en
dix-neuf 1810 je crois il a témoigné à
travers des dessins très très crus des
horaires des horreurs de la guerre
pratiquée par par les français et on
verra donc au fur et à mesure des
peintures qui vont raconter des choses
un peu moins officielles un peu plus
durs comme le guernica de picasso et
puis qui vont s'affronter qui vont aller
se confronter à des choses un petit peu
plus triviale donc cette irruption de du
peuple on va se frotter aux interdits de
la représentation principalement autour
de la sexualité avec différentes oeuvres
présentées rapidement de la religion la
représentation du religieux qui va venir
se frotter contre certains interdits et
certains dogmes et certaines icônes et
derniers représentent la dernière
tentation du christ qui donne lieu
forcément à des frictions et avec ddd
levée de boucliers de certains tenants
de la protection de leurs icônes et le
politique bien sûr avec la une
caricature louis philippe par daumier
topor caricature entre de gaulle pareil
figure tutélaire
été critiquée par le par le dessin la
rva aussi se frotter à l'art lui-même
qui est devenue icône à travers un
certain nombre de travaux ça va qu'il va
questionner le style l'implication dans
le dans le dans son univers avec des
chose d'emblématique vous avez vu ces
images là qui viennent un moment donné
questionner le sens et la signification
on termine avec cette image de duchamp
qui appareille gris fouillé une
barbichette et une moustache à la
joconde pareil ans daisy kono graciant
comment dire en en s'attaquant à des
symboles forts de l'art avec ses lettres
en dessous l h ou au cul qui sur le lit
d'un trait de veut dire tel h au cul et
on revient donc à cette image qui a posé
problème et qui était très critiqué en
essayant d'expliquer en quoi elle elle
raconte quelque chose qui n est
apparemment cruelle est apparemment
méchante elle est apparemment imparable
et 7 cette image nous raconte quand même
quelque chose de la fracture de notre
société entre d'un côté un enfant qui
meurt sur une plage et à côté une
société de consommation on a le même
problème avec 7,7
cette image où on a on voit qu'on a deux
de comportement différent dans le dans
l'appréciation de des deux événements
d'un côté une comment dire une beaucoup
d'émotion par rapport par rapport à
evans et puis de l'autre quelque chose
de beaucoup plus négatif par rapport à
ce qui s'est passé à munich et avec des
amalgames et puis un peu de racisme ses
dessins ils viennent nous frotter là
dessus et nous questionner sur le sens
qu'on donne aux choses voilà d'après on
a des choses un peu plus compassionnel
par rapport à la mort d ilan qui frise
un peu à mon avis le mauvais goût et le
ridicule quand on a envie d'être dans le
compassionnel
voilà donc ce que je veux
dire c'est que l'humour à 3 6 à 3 il ya
trois éléments importants dans l'humour
la première c'est de m l'émotionnel à
distance donc à partir du moment où on
fait de l'humour on n'est plus dans le
compassionnel on n'est plus dans le
temps le dans l'aimable et c est le lot
rire permet de réfléchir au sens des
choses ensuite deuxième chose l'humour
c'est également une critique sociale
cela quand on dit quelque chose c'est
parce que quelque chose n'est pas normal
quand quelqu'un de tomber qu'on rigole
c'est parce qu'il n'aurait pas dû tomber
donc à lhassa aussi cette fonction là
la troisième chose très importante et à
mon avis fondamental c'est que l'humour
c'est une connivence
c'est à dire qu'il faut quand on fait de
l'humour avec des gens qu'on connaît
on peut rire des mêmes choses dès que le
trait d'humour sort du cercle et qui a
plus cette connivence à sont là il peut
y avoir mauvaise interprétation
et on peut tomber dans les problèmes
qu'on a pu rencontrer sur
l'interprétation de dessins entre autres
de ceux de charlie hebdo
voilà on terminait une image de goya qui
dit que chi chi le le le conduire le
texte qui est écrit sur le sur le bloc
dit que le songe de le sommeil de la
raison produit des monstres donc on est
bien un petit peu dans ce cadre là et
puis je termine avec un dessin de riser
qui est un des dessinateurs
à mon avis le plus talentueux et le plus
rentre dedans et les plus agressifs et
puis qui s'adresse un peu à ce qui
aurait peut-être pas tout entendu
voilà merci à tous
[Applaudissements]